[Music]
as we have throughout this pandemic we
want to take a moment to tell you about
some of the remarkable people we've lost
excuse me - the corona virus while some
were known to the world
others were known only to loved ones but
all made a significant difference here
are just some of the many lives to
remember Jeanne Shay was a legendary DJ
in Philadelphia this is 88 5xp and the
photo on gmj the Dean of Philly's folk
scene was on the air for more than 50
years Shay and his wife Gloria brought
Bob Dylan to Philly for the first time
Joni Mitchell debuted her song both
sides now on Shea's show he co-founded
and hosted the Philadelphia Folk
Festival
I'll tell the joke tonight for Shea's
final show in 2015 more than 100
musicians serenaded him gene Shea was 85
and Sullivan was an ink and paint artist
on many classic Disney films born in
Fargo North Dakota
Sullivan moved to Los Angeles in 1949
where she landed a job at Walt Disney in
their animation paint lab Sullivan left
her job to raise four children but after
a divorce rejoined Disney to work on the
Little Mermaid The Lion King and Mulan
daughter Shannon J remembers waiting
with her mom to see her name in the
closing credits that's such an honor she
said for her to come from a small town
and make it is just remarkable and
Sullivan was 91
Kim early win taught English at the
Brooklyn Latin School in New York her
energy was irresistible said her friend
Cindy Martinez Angeles the daughter of
Cambodian immigrants
she played rugby at Vassar a talented
writer she'd been published in literary
journals and was working on a novel
about the immigrant experience the whole
work and she lit sparks in the minds of
her students you saw something in me
that I didn't see one wrote on a tribute
page I know you are watching over all of
us and still believe in us
Kimberly Wynn was 33 Robby Brown was a
real estate broker to the stars in New
York with clients like Rosie O'Donnell
Uma Thurman's and Alec Baldwin but
friends knew him as a Pied Piper who
brought people together and a leader in
the LGBTQ community who after his
brother's death from AIDS raised
millions for charity in 1994 he competed
as a diver in the gay games and won his
division his friend Olympic gold
medalist Greg Louganis famously rewarded
him with a kiss one of the first gay
kisses to air on mainstream news as
Robbie said in a documentary by his
friend Jeff Despres I know it's so hard
to find one's way in life I want people
to live and be proud of who they are
because there's not much time Robbie
Brown was 72 Joyce mokuba's LeBlanc was
a nurse for more than 30 years in
Chicago working in the intensive care
unit at University of Illinois Hospital
she was nurturing to whoever needed it
friend and fellow nurse Aileen Fajardo
Ferland said born in the Philippines she
arrived in Chicago at age 7
with her husband Lawrence LeBlanc she
raised two boys now in college she is
the best thing that ever happened to me
Lawrence said I went to sleep the
luckiest man alive
and woke up the saddest man alive
Joyce mokuba's LeBlanc was 53
Simon press was a gym teacher
at college achieved charter school in
Asbury Park New Jersey and volunteered
with the local Boys and Girls Club known
for his gentle spirits and boundless
enthusiasm he could make every person
little or big feel like they were
important said principal Jody McInerney
his whole goal was to give the students
a better life than their parents were
given raised in Asbury Park himself
press played semi-pro football and
planned to try out for the NFL this
season when the pandemic closed school
he taught gym class by a zoom before
becoming ill he was always trying to
turn a negative into a positive
said Simon's mom Sabrina slaughter I'm
very very proud of my son Simon press
was 27